our next guest can help you find a new
job if you're looking to change careers
LinkedIn has released a list of the top
20 skills that employers are looking for
when making new hires those skills
include an ability with social media and
ability to manage time leadership
problem solving also Financial skills
LinkedIn career expert Catherine Fisher
joins us now with more on this Catherine
good morning good morning uh so people
are looking less at where he went to
school and instead asking can you do the
job and that means soft skills yes so
when we looked at some of the top skills
in a lot of the job listings on LinkedIn
those soft skills are really coming
through so like you said problem solving
communication leadership companies want
to know that you can do like they assume
that you can do the job and they can
test you with this in interviews like
with writing skills Etc but how are you
with those problem solving especially as
companies are really trying to figure
out this new way of working you know a
lot of companies you know are we doing
flexible work are we not as we're
approaching these headwinds with the
economy me can you help us grow and
scale the business so those skills are
really important so how did it used to
be Catherine companies would look at
what and now they're looking at what you
know they used to look at your degree
where you went to school but now they're
looking at what skills you've acquired
whether you have a degree or not it
depends on the role but what really
depends is those skills that you've
acquired through your career and so now
people used to look at their job as I'm
going to get this job and then I'm going
to go to the next and it was the latter
right now it's about a collection of
skills and what's good about this is
that really crosses any industry or job
and you can acquire those skills in so
many different ways and you say it's
important to sell yourself it is and so
toot your own horn absolutely you should
always be selling yourself and whether
you're looking for a job or getting you
know even if you're happy in your job
you should be always looking at what are
the most in-demand skills so how do you
do that how do you to your for example
you can say listen I'm very yeah I'm
very good at you know working with
people or yeah what am I supposed to do
because there's a fine line between
again between confidence and Cockiness
yes yes the sports background and they
say we'd rather you be cocky and go out
there and believe in yourself as long as
you can back it up how do you feel like
people should talk about their own
skills you have to be able to
storytelling you need to have concrete
examples of where you've applied this
yeah okay so for example
um I was actually just talking to a
woman I know who her first job in PR
um she got it because she had bartending
on her resume and her hiring manager and
she thought maybe I shouldn't include
that on my resume and the hiring manager
said no because of you have those great
skills
um but then also as as you go in to sell
it you need to be able to show hey you
know so I had this problem let's say you
were in working for a food bank right
right and they were having issues with
the food going bad overnight when people
would make donations you you know did a
whole campaign you got a refrigerator
and then you were able to increase the
donations and you know fewer less food
went bad so it's really show showing
those specific examples of how it um
there are fewer hires being made across
the economy but there's one sector in
particular that's adding jobs what is
that yes well think of that as we're
heading into the holiday season it's
shipping it's Logistics it's Supply so
it's when you're purchasing an item how
you get it from you know the the
shipping container to the warehouse you
you wrap it up you ship it you take it
to your home all of those jobs all those
jobs
yes exactly and it's great for seasonal
work all right very cool maybe Tom Brady
we're making a LinkedIn profile
they're looking for a job he's got soft
skills yes he does he does right he got
lost I said he's gone sloth with age
thank you Catherine thank you